c'est quand je regarde ce qui a été
annoncé nous on a fait beaucoup de
propositions pendant cette période pour
qu'il y ait des réponses pour tous les
français la danse qui a été annoncé il
ya encore beaucoup d'oublier prenons
deux exemples que vous avez donné
d'abord les retraités
vous l'avez dit en 2019 les retraites ne
seront pas réévalué de l'inflation il va
falloir attendre 2020 pour certains
retraités 2021 pour les autres et toute
une partie des retraités vont continuer
à payer les hausses de cfg ça veut dire
quoi
ça veut dire qu'en deux ans président de
la république a pris 6 à 8 milliards
d'euros sur le dos des retraités et qui
ne leur rend pas cet argent
ça n'est pas digne le deuxième exemple
c'est l'essence le prix de l'essence
avait explosé les hausses de taxes qui
ont été appliquées en 2018
le président n'a même pas parlé dans son
intervention il n'envisage pas de les
annuler ce qui signifie qui n'a toujours
pas compris ce qu'est la réalité des
français qui vont travailler en prenant
leur automobile et donc dans ce qui est
annoncé peut-être des petits gestes
peut-être des petites corrections des
lourdes erreurs commises mais surtout
aussi des compartiments entier des
français qui ne sont pas concernés la
deuxième chose qui me frappe c'est
comment on finance
aucune piste sérieuse d'économies sur la
dépense publique qui ont été mis sur la
table sérieuse les français sont pas
dupes
là on est avant les élections donc on a
les bonnes nouvelles mais après qu'est
ce qui se passera ma crainte c'est que
les cadeaux d'aujourd'hui qui sont
financés à coups de déficits budgétaires
eh bien ça face les impôts de demain et
ça ça peut pas être une solution viable
le président de la république a renoncé
par exemple à la seule piste d'économies
concrètes sur laquelle il s'était engagé
qui était la baisse du nombre de
fonctionnaires et donc les français
peuvent très bien comprendre la vérité a
pas d'économie il n'y a pas de baisses
d'impôts possible il n'y a pas de baisse
durable
ça veut dire qu'à un moment on reviendra
ce qui s'est passé au cours des deux ans
qui viennent de s'écouler dans la poche
des français